In the last lesson, we learned how our genomes are made of a chemical substance
called DNA, which holds all the information we need to make up who we are.
>> And in this lesson, we're going to talk about
our cells transform genetic information into our flesh and blood.
>> Quite literally, in fact. We're going to focus on
a process that's referred to in biology as the central
dogma. Central, because it's true for virtually all life. The
processes of transcription and translation. Which will turn our DNA
genetic code into the protein of who we are. And to
do this, we're going to focus on the trait of blood type.
>> So you're talking about, like, A, B, A positive,
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Exactly. You probably heard of these blood
types before. They're referred to as the ABO
blood types. And there are pretty important to
know, especially if you are in the doctor's office.
>> That's true. In fact, over 15 million people per year
had donated blood in the US alone, and over 5 million
people per year received blood transfusions. So knowing your blood type
can help save your life or the life of someone else.
>> It's actually a lot of people
[UNKNOWN],
some of you might even know your blood type, and so
we want you to tell us if you know it. Are you
type A, B, AB, or O? And if you know about
your positive or negative factor, don't worry about that for right now.